السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
السلام الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان لا
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول الله
حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
الحمد لله ثم الحمد
لله نحمده ونشكره ونستغفره ونستعين به
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له له الملك وله الحمد يحيي
ويميت وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد وعلى
ال وصحبه اجمعين وعلى من تبعهم باحسان الى
يوم الدين اما بعد قال الله تعالى في كتاب
المبين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا
تموتن الا
وانتم
مسلمون صدق الله العظيم
[Silence]
تالى
اللهى الله
‏things so challenges
we one of us and our families today i'd
to look at perhaps some of the
potential we have as muslims in america
at this time and some of the potential
we have to make posi changes here to
make posi ches in this country and we
always take surve a little bit as we
‏there been some fascinating surveys
that are done by professional
organizations the pew organization
which find that masallah 88% of
americans believe in god or some higher
power 88% that's way higher than in
europe that's way higher than in many
many places
interestingly only 54% of americans
believe in a god that's described in the
bible so there's a big gap there there's
a big gap between people who believe
‏religion they init are providing answ
that they find
saory also over 80 amans
20 over 83%
americans hum soul
‏know teach elementary mid school how
much the soul is
about that's a very large number of
people and that's that's very promising
because if you believe that we have a
soul and if you believe that part of
being a human being one of the
objectives is to purify that soul is to
enhance that soul is to treat other
souls embodied souls other people with
kindness this op up potentially someone
to ‏believing more easily in
islam also very interestingly in these
surve a different but done in 2021 only
63% of americans identified as
christian this is very surprising and
even the posters were surprised because
10 years earlier 73% did so something
happening in
america and this is i think there a lot
of
poti a lot of people are ‏question may
their inherited bel and quan talks a l
about people questioning their inherited
bel saying we do this because our
ancestors
did and so there's a lot of potential
here and so today i'd highlight
three passes in the ho qu that i think
can be very eyeing and helpful for our
fellow christian citizens in this
country and neighbors and
so
come may
عليه
الس 171
اللهى اللهى بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا اهل التاب لا تخلوا في دين ولا
تقولوا على الله الا الحى
[Silence]
المسيح عسى ابن مريم رسول الله
وكلمته القاها الى مريم وحظ
‏jesus son of mary of of mary عليه was
only a messenger of
allah only a messenger fully human and
his word which he cast into mary because
عليه was created in a way different from
the way most human beings are created
and a spirit from him and there many
interpretations that means we're not
going to worry about that right now but
the ke message here is ان المسح مريم
رسول
الله
mary
aeng عليه
السلام الله تعالى فامنوا بالله
ورس ولا
تقولوا اللهى
‏all مصل
علم
not ولا
تقول انته
لالى انم الله
ال
الله
سبحانه ان
[Silence]
له له ما في السماوات وما فيض وف بالله
وكي صدق الله العظم الله
تعالى
sayan all
allent حسب
ونكح الله
‏politely right how
clearly that allaha is singular allah is
one hamdah we have debates over the
qualities of allah and names and so
forth hamdah that's something different
but allah is one that's something we all
agree upon and it's a message that we
can and we need to share politely among
our fellow americans in this country
also in this sur a little bit earlier in
verse 157
‏the
people
in الله تالى وما قتلوه وما صبوه ولكن ش
لقظ
اللهى عل
‏jeu is very differ between isam and
chr و
شب complicated expr for day but it was
made to that but this is a very
important difference teaching that we
need to hold firm to as
muslim we crosses every in country there
رما قتلوه وما
صبه سبحان
الله يا بني اسرايل اني رسول الله الي
مصدقا لما بين يدي من الترات مبشرا
برسول من بعض اسمه احمد صق الله
العظم عليه
‏understanding of the mion ofa alam that
prophet mammam was sent to the whole
world anda was sent toam was sent
israelites this is what the message this
is whom isa alam is adding here the
israelites and he saying i am a
messenger of god to
verify and to
clarify the scripture that came before
me
the and to give good news of a messenger
whose name is
‏as any who arabic knows and are from
the right not the ex word but from
the interchangeable considered one
theed
علس i was a student many years ago in
yemen i heard a st about some europeans
who volunteering there mas they doing
good deeds but they also kind trying to
get musim to become chran and they tried
the whole well you jesus we likees
‏jes that
kindo and the y very very they said
aha عليه السلام pr محد صلى الله عليه
وسل that's the that's عليه
السران and my understanding is they
didn't have a good answer to
that they w really sure they thought
they kind got these
الله عليه
السلام to a limited community to clarify
to explain the scripture
meaning and to let them know that
another prophet another messenger was
going to follow in his footsteps and
that messenger any messengers عليه and
محسم
‏was
the
حمه الله صح
البخاري صل الله عليه
وسلم انا اول الناسن م في الدن والخره ما
الله world near
‏alles
والبيا
لهم
ش
ودين teeng
‏wor
alleng
teach
te صل الله عليه
وسلم
in رايت عسى وموسى
وابراهيم علسلم صح بخاري حث
فاما عيسى فاحمر ج عض
صدر
ج واما موسى فادم
جسيم كانه من رجال الز
‏was
br
white عل brown comple straight hair and
tall stature as if he was from the
people of who understood probably be
people from south asia who settled in
arab and known for having some darker
shades
skin blessed our community truth
nature truth nature
عليه عليه
وسم especially in country where islam is
poorly known and underst and we have
freedom to talk about religion we have
many neighbors and fellow cens who are
very interested in learning more curious
already have a belief inal it might not
be the correct belief but it's one
perhaps we can help them and educate
them as they go along their journeys ازو
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم بعد
الله استغفر الله ان الله غفور
[Silence]
الرحيم الحمد لله الحمد اشهد اله الا الله
وحده لا شر له واشهد ان محمدا عبده وسوله
الل صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وحه
اجم
الله الله
الفاتحه
سقران
اللهى
القره ايه اللهى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
واقيموا الصلاه وات وعع
[Silence]
‏way was
together عليهم
‏can maybe don't feel we have very
maybe we in may we are pay pay
and صل الله
عليهم us a
[Silence]
حديث الله صل الله عليه وسم سلام من الناس
عليه صدقه كل يوم تطلع فيه
الشمس الله صل علسلم
[Silence]
‏ex ما الله صل
علس تعدلين اثنين
صدقه
وترج في دابته فتحمله عليها او ترفع له
عليها
[Silence]
صقه والمه طيبه صدقه ما شا الله والمه
طيبه صدقه
وبكل خطوه تمشيها الى الصلاه
[Silence]
صدقه take acc te
‏ull out i have careful
[Silence]
علق
الله ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عب النار ربنا لا تؤخذنا ان
نسينا واخط
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اسرا كما حملت الذين
من قبلنا ربنا ولا تحملنا ملا طاقه لنا به
واعف عنا واغفر لنا وارحمنا انت مولانا
فانصرنا على قوم كافرين سبحان ربك رب
العزه عما يصفون والسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين عباد الله ان الله
يامر بالعدل والحسان واء ذ القربا وينهانا
الفحشاء والمنكر والخي يعذ لعلكم تذكرون
اذكروا الله واقم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
[Silence]
الله pleas
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم سبح لله ما في السماوات وما في
الارض وهو العزيز
الحكيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لما تقولون ما لا
تفعلون كبر مقتا عند الله ان تقولوا ما لا
تفعلون ان الله يحب الذين
يقاتلون في سبيله صفا كانهم بنيان
مرصوص واذ قال موسى لقومه يا قومي لما
تؤذن وقد تعلمون اني رسول الله
اليكم فلم لما زاخ وزخ الله قلوبهم الله
لا يهدي القوم
الفاسقين واذ قال عيسى ابن مريم يا بني
اسرائيل اني رسول الله اليكم مصدق لما بين
يدي من التوراه مبشرا برسول ياتي من
بعض اسمه
احمد فلما جاءوا بالبينات قالوا هذا سحر
مبين ومن اظم ممن افترى على الله الكذب
وهو يدعى على
الاسلام والله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين يريدون ليطفئ نور الله بافواههم
والله متم نور
ولو كره
الكافرون هو
الذي ارسل رسوله بالهدى ودين الحق ليظهره
على الدين
كله ولو كره
المشركون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك اك
نستعين اهدنا صراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم قل هو الله احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد
الله
اك سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله السلام علي ورحمه الله
وبركاته جزاك الله خيرا جزاء الله سبحان
وتال
[Silence]
‏coming
from next coming also has a booke did a
mon ag inen have a book launch
[Silence]
‏high ‏i've been here almost four years
he hasn't been in here for last four
years he been quite busy so you should
defin take advantage of him mentioned
this before several times i mention it
again and i'm proud of that in s we
classmates not scott and i and are
classmates and bchm so in great
knowledge come and join and the benit
from
it ta if you are still w to know how to
do that if you in of
‏some
[Silence]
‏people
some
great it
takes
[Silence]
notcourses that's
‏can as
asib st for
pleas
tour
present
us inter
[Silence]
‏make
لامكم ورحمه